Vous entendez ?
Ce sont des flamants roses.
Il y ena partout autour de moi.
Je suis en Camargue, au Parc Ornithologique du Pont de Gau.
Des flamantsroses en liberté, impossible de louper ces grands oiseaux,
ils mesurent 1m60 tout en étant légerscomme une plume.
Pas plus de 3 kg et puis leur couleur, rose, on a l'impression qu'ils sont
tombés dans un pot de peinture.
Allez, suivez-moi à l'atelier, on va éclaircir tout ça.
Pas tropquand même hein, parce qu'ils sont jolis en rose.
un flamant ne né pas rose mais avec un duvet
gris. Ce duvet s'éclaircit puis les plumes poussent blanches
avec des extrémités noires au bout desailes.
L'oiseau ne se colore vraiment qu'au fildu temps
en grandissant et c'est au bout de trois ansenviron,
lorsqu'il devient adulte qu'un flamant rose, est enfin rose.
Flamand...Flamand, Flamande !
Qui vient de Flandre.
Mais non, l'oiseau, le flamant rose, s'écrit avec un "T" à la fin
et nonavec un "D" comme les flamands, les habitants desFlandres.
Le nom "flamant rose" trouve son origine
dans l'occitan "flamenc" qui veut dire flammes.
Il fait référence évidemment, à la couleur flamboyante
de cette famille d'oiseaux, les flamants,
qui compte six espèces d'un rose plus ou moins soutenu
etce n'est pas, malgré son nom,
le "flamant rose", le plus rose de tous mais son cousin :
le "Flamantdes Caraïbes" dont les plumes virent carrément
au rouge corail.
Mais comment fabriquent-t-ils ce rosesi particulier ?
Grâce à leur nourriture.
Allez, on file au resto !
Bien alors, qu'est ce qu'on mange ici?
Des algues microscopiques, de petits crustacés et également des petits mollusques.
Cette nourritureest très abondante dans cette eau vaseuse et salée.
elle est également très riche en caroténoïdes,
un pigment rouge orangé, le même que celui qu'on retrouve dans les carottes.
Au cours de la digestion, les flamants synthétisent ce pigment et l'absorbent.
On le retrouve ensuite dans les graisses, dans
les pattes et au niveau des ailes.
Mais comme si ça ne suffisait pas, les flamants ici,
en rajoutentune couche.
Je vais vous montrer.
Les flamants roses fabriquent en plus une substance grasse
etrose bien sûr, qu'ils récupèrent au niveau d'une glande
située sous leur croupion le croupion.
Lecroupion... Sous le croupion ?!
Ils puisent de la graisse avec leur bec
au niveau de cette glande.
Je sais, c'est bizarre.
Puis, ils lissent leurs plumes, ajoutant ainsi un maquillage
lustrant et rose sur leur plumage déjà coloré.
Ily a cependant un moment dans la vie
du flamant où sa couleur change.
Lorsqu'il élève sonunique petit de l'année, au printemps.
Ils pâlissent car à ce moment-là, les parents fabriquent
etrégurgitent une sorte de lait, du lait de jabot comme l'on dit,
très concentré en caroténoïdes pourjustement
nourrir le petit, si bien qu'au bout de plusieurs semaines de nourrissage,
eh bien il n'estpas rare de voir leurs plumes devenir quasiment blanches.
Normal, puisque les caroténoïdes sontutilisés
pour nourrir le petit.
Chaque hiver, des flamants roses se regroupent ici pour
la paradenuptiale.
Il y en a près de 20 000 autour de nous.
Pendant plusieurs semaines, mâles et femelles exécutent
deschorégraphies très codifiées pour se séduire les uns les autres,
pour former des couples qui vont durer
le temps d'une saison, le temps de faire un poussin.
Alors les scientifiques ont observé 8 postures
et 17 enchainements différents.
Ce qui fait un total de 136 combinaisons.
Du coup, l'hiverest la meilleure saison pour observer
les "Bécaru", c'est comme ça qu'appelle les flamants en Provence.
Parcequ'en plus d'avoir une couleur particulière, ils ont aussi vous l'aurez
sûrement remarqué, un bectrès particulier pour des oiseaux
qui vivent les pieds dans l'eau.
Un bec recourbé vers lebas.
Je vais vous montrer !
Pour se nourrir, le flamant rose plonge la tête dans l'eau.
Puis, il recourbele cou et il avance la tête à l'envers.
C'est finalement le haut son bec qui racle le sol vaseux.
Un peu comme on le fait avec une épuisette.
Ça fonctionne un peu comme une cafetière à piston.
Le fond de la cafetière correspond au dessus de son bec et le piston à sa langue.
Le flamand faitrentrer de l'eau qui contient de la nourriture
dans son bain puis il appuie avec sa langue
commeon appuie avec le piston.
L'eau est chassée sur les côtés par de petits orifices.
On les voit bien icices petits orifices que l'on compare souvent
aux fanons de la baleine.
Il appuie donc avecsa langue, l'eau est chassée puis il récupère
la nourriture sur sa langue et il n'a plus qu'àavaler.
Il a même développé une technique bien à lui, on peut le voir parfois
tourner en rondautour de son bec plongé dans l'eau
en remuant ses pattes dans le sol.
Les cercles qu'il laissederrière lui sont un indice de son passage.
Et ce n'est pas tout.
Regardez, ils tiennent surune patte.
Compliqué pour nous, pas pour un flamant.
S'installer sur une patte et dormir c'estmême la position
la plus reposante pour ce genre d'oiseau.
Je vais vous montrer, on va les laisser dormir...
Tout est une affaired'équilibre.
Dans cette position unijambiste, l'une des pattes est repliée
sous l'aile tandis quel'autre se trouve
pile à la verticale du centre de gravité de l'animal.
Les muscles de sa patteporteuse ne sont donc pas tendus
par l'effort, contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait penser, mais au repos.
Le flamant ne fatigue pas du tout, à tel point que même mort,
le flamant rose peut tenirdebout dans cette position.
Alors pour réaliser une telle prouesse,
le flamant peut comptersur sa cheville.
Eh oui, l'articulation que l'on voit au milieu de la patte,
ici, c'est sa cheville.
Le genou, lui, se cache au niveau du corps, là,
et c'est lui qui se plie sous l'aile quand l'oiseautient sur une patte.
En somme pour lui, tenir sur une seule patte,
c'est comme être agenouillé.
Allez, j'y retourne parce que c'est vraiment
une histoire à dormir debout.
A bientôt !
Mâles etfemelles exécutent des... des...
Se cache... le genou... se cache...